Você sabia que a doença que matou mais
de 2 milhões de marinheiros nas grandes
navegações acaba de reaparecer na
Austrália? Pois é, estou falando
escorbuto. Olha só que impressionante.
Um homem de 51 anos chegou no hospital
com erupções dolorosas nas pernas,
sangramento e anemia. Os médicos fizeram
1000 exames e nada. Sabe quando
descobriram? Quando perguntaram o que
que ele andava comendo. O cara tinha
feito cirurgia bariátrica, passou por
problemas financeiros e simplesmente
parou de comer frutas e vegetais.
Resultado, excurbutem. Veja bem, a falta
de vitamina C não é brincadeira e o pior
é que você nem precisa chegar ao corbuto
para sentir os efeitos. Deficiências
moderadas de vitamina C são super comuns
e causam fadiga crônica, dores nas
circulações, problemas de pele,
imunidade baixa. Muita gente sofre com
esses sintomas e nem imagina que pode
ser falta de vitamina C. Então fica a
dica, dá uma olhada na sua alimentação
dessa semana, quantas frutas você comeu
e vegetais frescos. Yeah.